[Musique]
non
le super bowl vient de nous régaler avec
un petit teaser d'avengers 4 alors
effectivement il n'y a rien non plus
d'incroyable pour ce trailer
les pubs du super bowl sont chers et on
ne pouvait pas espérer plus que 30
secondes
néanmoins je pense que nous pouvons
adéquatement tirer quelques théories de
ce teaser et je vous propose donc mon
analyse 100% personnel les années déjà
résumons brièvement le contexte ne
s'éloigne pas beaucoup du premier
trailer
ce teaser semble nous montrer les
conséquences du claquement de doigts de
thanos et potentiel retour de nos
avengers stratégie importante de marvel
qui ne souhaite pas dévoiler trop sur le
film mais plutôt sur le début de celui
ci bref attaquons les théories et
l'analyse
[Musique]
premièrement marvel possède une mission
très difficile en termes d'équilibrage
des héros à l'écran
certains se plaignaient du peu
d'apparitions de héros dans une finity
war et ce sera certainement un peu le
cas pour avengers 4 néanmoins pas au
début du film
évidemment toutefois si nous re
visionner le premier trailer ainsi que
le teaser qui vient de nous être
proposées le film semble très clairement
tourné autour de captain america soit
steve rodgers effectivement steve est le
premier des avengers celui qui motive et
dirige les troupes
généralement nous sommes face à un
retour aux sources des plus imminent
comparé à ventures iii où ce dernier
subissait plus qu'il ne dirigeait pour
moi et j'en reste encore assez convaincu
des héros mourront dans avengers 4 et
plus particulièrement steve rogers ou
certainement tony stark
pourquoi accès les deux trailer sur le
captain peut être pour clôturer son
origin story et ses aventures dans le mc
eu l'option du voyage dans le temps avec
peggy carter n'est pas à négliger non
plus en parlant de voyage dans le temps
tiens je reste le plus fidèles partisans
de cette idée on en a parlé énormément
de fois sur la chaîne et je reste
toujours convaincu le trailer
après mois le suppose de nouveau de
façon assez philosophique
alors attention je vais partir très loin
au moment exact où steve mentionne le
fait que certains renoncent mes panneaux
nous avons l'image d'un grand père avec
marc et where do we go now that they are
gone que nous pourrions traduire
vulgairement par où pouvons-nous aller
maintenant qu'ils sont tous partis
évidemment cette phrase est en référence
à la grosse réflexions et décisions que
vont prendre nous avons jones restant
par rapport aux conséquences d'une
finity war le grand père ici symbolise
pour moi la vie qui avancent et que le
passé est derrière nous d'où le fait
qu'il tourne le dos mais lorsque nos
proches sont tous partis où aller les
ombres derrière le grand-père symbolise
le passé et les gens disparus le seul
moyen de les retrouver et de retourner
en arrière et de se rappeler deux la
métaphore ici serait que les héros
disparus soit symbolisée par les ombres
et nos avengers restant par le
grand-père le seul moyen de les
retrouver serait de retourner en arrière
pour les ramener c'est une vision propre
à moi à vous de me dire dans les
commentaires ce que vous en pensez
et comment on vous l'interprétez mais
n'oubliez jamais qu'avec marvel rien
n'est laissé au hasard
d'ailleurs barton semble avoir remballé
son costume de ronin pour celui de
hawkeye est ce dû à un retour dans le
temps ou simplement un retour du
personnage dans le bon côté entre
guillemets enfin le dernier gros point
important pour moi et l'absence de
thanos et c'est pour moi hyper important
de le noter
thanos a disparu comme je vous l'affirmé
dans de précédentes vidéos
sa mission est accomplie il n'y a plus
de raison qu'il soit présent pour le
moment même si nous savons que thanos
will return
mais dans le cas de ce teaser l'absence
de thanos symbolise le fait que les
avengers vont devoir se passer de
simplement retrouver le titan pour
inverser le processus et qu'un autre
moyen devra être trouvée pour sauver les
héros disparus but accentuée par le
début du trailer montrant chaque héros
important disparu avec le claquement de
doigts je ne sais pas si vous voyez ce
que je veux dit
mais tanoh sera dans le film évidemment
vous inquiétez pas pour alimenter ce si
j'aimerais affirmer haut et fort que le
film se découpera en trois visions tony
et nebula sont coincés sur titan sans
vaisseau potable le vaisseau des
gardiens a très certainement dû subir la
pluie de météores provoqué par thanos
ils devront trouver un moyen de quitter
la planète pour retrouver les autres
d'où le fait qu'ils sont en train de
faire de la mécanique
ensuite nous aurons la vision principale
celle du capitaine guy dans les derniers
avengers thor est en verre une mission
que seul lui et natacha ont en tête eu
certainement scotland
je crois toujours à fond qu'il s'agit du
voyage en temps je ne vois pas d'autres
solutions
enfin un dernier point de vue et qui n'a
pas encore été mentionné de trop sur la
chaîne mais dont je suis convaincu
celui de thor et rocket tort et
roquettes ont tout perdu amis et famille
tort n'a plus de famille et vient de
perdre l'eau qui est m dalle il est
certainement convaincu également que la
totalité des asgardiens sont tous morts
de la main de thanos requête quant à lui
a perdu chaque membre des gardiens dont
groth son allié de toujours les deux
personnages vont très certainement se
remettre en question et vont aussi avoir
soif de vengeance requête ne connaît que
thor avec qui il a partagé énormément de
péripéties dans avengers 3 et c'est
également le seul héros à venir de
l'espace soit un petit point commun les
deux personnages vont forcément être
ensemble ce qui me fait également penser
ceci et que thor semble être à la
poursuite de thanos car nous voyons se
tenir là où la noce se reposer suite aux
évènements d'infinity ward la cabane de
bord de mer que rocket découvre peut
très certainement être un abri de
fortune du titan leur cavale les
mèneront obligatoirement à walkyrie qui
est présente dans le film ainsi que les
derniers asgardiens survivants
voilà ce que je pense en tout cas
j'espère que cette petite vidéo vous
aura plu les amis activer la cloche si
vous le souhaitez ne louper aucune de
mes prochaines vidéos c'est très
important à mettre à pouss bleus à vous
abonner
vous pouvez également me soutenir
financièrement sur un type ou me suivre
sur twitter 7 et arago rock et que le
'lion' earth soit avec vous à bientôt
pour du marvel
[Musique]